انطلقت في ماليزيا صباح اليوم عمليه
التصويت في الانتخابات ال15 الاختيار نواب
البرلمان المركزي واعضاء مجلس تشريعيه
محليه لثلاثي ولايات من بين 13 ولايه
وتتنافسوا في الانتخابات ست كتل الحزبيه
رئيسيه ابرزها تحالف الجبهه الوطنيه
وتحالف الامل وتحالف العقد الوطني وينحصر
السباق بين تيارين سياسيين الاول يدعو
للاصلاح ومكافحه الفساد بقياده زعيم
المعارضه انوار ابراهيم والثاني يدعو الى
عوده الاستقلال السياسي والحفاظ على حقوق
الاغلبيه المنويه
واستبعدت نتائج الاستطلاعات فوز ايا من
الكتل الحزبيه في الانتخابات مرجحه سنه
رموز سياسيه كبيره
من امام احد مراكز الاقتراع في كوالالمبور
مدير مكتب الجزيره سامر علاوي ينضم الينا
اذا انطلقت عمليه التصويت
واستطاعات الراي لا تبشر الاحزاب الكبرى
كيف يبدو الوضع
المبكر بشكل عادي وطبيعي و بدون اي خلل في
جميع انحاء ماليزيا في قسمينها الشرقيه
والغربيه بعض حوادث
الفيضانات التي حدثت في دوائر انتخابيه في
ولايه السروات في القسم الشرقي من البلاد
اا عمليه الاقتراع في هذا همم
المركز في همم احد احيائكم الانبور
الشعبيه همم تيسير بالسيكل طبيعي وسلس
ودول ايه مشاكل همم المسؤولون هنا اخبرونا
ان اكثر من 70% من من يحق لهم حق الاطراع
همم الدب باصواتهم حتى الساعه الواحد بعد
الظهر قبل ساعتين تقريبا من الان واا
يتوقع ان تزيد هذه النسبه مع مرور الوقت
رغم ان عدد المصوتين تراجع بعد
ظهر اليوم همم سقف التوقعات للاحزاب
السياسيه لم يكن كما كان عشيه هذه
الانتخابات يوم امس
حيث كانوا يقولون انهم سيحققونا فوزا
ساحقا خاصه تحالف الامل الذي يقوده انور
ابراهيم وتحالف الجبهه الوطنيه الذي حكم
ماليزيا لاكثر من سته عقود همم كل منهما
كان يدعي انه سيحكك فوزا ساحقا لكن همم
بعد
ظهر اليوم همم تراجعت هذه التوقعات ليصبح
يصبح الحديث عن قدرات كل منهما على تشكيل
حكومه ائتلافيه
همم باضافه الى الكتله التي يقودها ااه
انور ابراهيم فهو يطمح بان يستميل همم اا
بعض الاحزاب الصغيره خاصه الاحزاب
المتواجده في الاول التي تمثل القسم
الشرقي في ماليزيا ولايه صباح وسروال وهو
نفس الشيء الذي عبر عنه اسماعيل صبري همم
رئيس الوزراء او ااه القائم بحكومه
التصريف الاعمال همم وقال انه سيتمكن من
تشكيل الحكومه همم مع التحالفات همم خارج
الكتله الحزبيه التي يقودها همم التحالف
الجبهه الوطنيه همم في هذه الاثناء هناك
همم انطباع عام على ان همم بعض الشخصيات
السياسيه الكبيره قد تبنى بهزيمه مثل محي
الدين ياسين وهو همم شخصيه معروفه وكذا
رئيس وزراء سابق ونائب رئيس وزراء في همم
طرده من حزب امنه عام 2016 ثم شكل حزب همم
موحده همم من عدد من
التي خرجت من الاحزانها خاصه في عام 2020
عندما حلت حكومه همم مهاتير محمد وشكلت
حكومه محي الدين ياسين اضافه الى ذلك هناك
توقعات بخساره بخساره كبيره لحزب مهاتير
محمد ولا همم وليس هناك الثقه كذلك من قبل
استطلاع الراس
بان مهاتير قد يكون هو همم بشخصه يفوز في
همم دائره جزيره لنكاوي التي داب على
الفوز فيها منذ عده عقود من امام احد
مراكز الاقتراع في العاصمه كوالالمبور
المدير مكتبه الجزيره سامر علاوي شكرا
جزيلا